une vague de violence sans précédent
s'est abattue sur le quartier
saint-jacques de bonnes
vers 1h30 cette nuit une quinzaine de
jeunes discutent et jouent à la console
quand une renault clio rouge arrive à
grande vitesse depuis l'ère de jeu le
conducteur tente de les percuter les
arrive à ce niveau là et commence à nous
agresser et nous ont coursés
heureusement qu'il ya le banc qui m'a
sauvé honnêtement sans sens bon là je
pense vraiment que c'était fini pour moi
parce que la voiture j'ai vu alors à
leur regard qu'ils avaient haine envers
nous et le percer des propos comme quoi
qu'on était des [__] et qu'on
avait rien à faire dans ce pays et que
c'était qu'ils allaient revenir qui a
livré trois jeunes sont légèrement
blessés ils partent aux urgences
convaincu qu'il s'agit d'un acte isolé
peut être dû à l'alcool mais vers 4h30
une voiture s'arrête au niveau du groupe
le passager tir quatre coups de feu avec
un fusil de chasse de petit calibre
sept jeunes âgés de 16 à 20 ans sont
blessés dont un grièvement
catherine et dans les premiers à leur
porter secours
je fais des 100 l'upj entendu pleurer
appelé les pompiers appelé les pompiers
et en effet il y avait des blessés mais
ça je comprends pas c'est la première
fois que ça arrive
les jeunes assure ne pas connaître les
agresseurs ils excluent l'idée d'un
règlement de compte et parle d'un acte
raciste perpétré au hasard si dd raciste
quand il cherchait la bagarre tout
simplement et sans ils ont dit qu'ils
allaient revenir avec un fusil voilà
quoi ils sont venus et puis ils ont tiré
quoi partir une s'y attendait aucune
piste n'est privilégiée par les
enquêteurs du commissariat de beaune et
de la pj de dijon
l'étude des images de vidéosurveillance
permettra peut-être de retrouver les
véhicules incriminés
le maire de beaune alain suguenot
envisage la mise en place d'un
couvre-feu pour les mineurs dans les
quartiers saint jacques et blanches
fleurs